-Our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated writer and actor
you know best from her work on
the critically acclaimed show
"Catastrophe."
You can see her next
in "Together,"
which is in theaters
this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-I vividly remember
being at dinner with him
and watching him eat
and just thinking,
"It's the worst thing
I've ever experienced."
-What?
I'm not -- I'm not a bad eater.
-No, it's not -- it's not that
you're a bad eater.
It's just like -- It's just
the fact of you eating.
Like, watching you eat makes
all the various different
processes involved
more apparent.
You know, like, mastication and
rending of flesh,
grinding of matter,
just mixing with saliva
and sucking it down
into your big old meat bowl
of acid to break it down
until it's no more than
a brown sausage of turd
to be squeezed out by your anus.
-Please welcome back to the show
Sharon Horgan.
How are you, Sharon?
-I'm okay. What a funny clip.
-It's the --
I watched that clip today
and was filled with dread
knowing that
when my wife watches it,
that will be when
she most thinks of me.
-That's exactly what she's
thinking as she watches you eat.
-Word for word.
With less style,
but word-for-word.
You -- I feel like you continue
to be our greatest creator
of content about marriage that
makes us both think
it's awful and worth it.
-Oh, well, thank you very much.
But, I mean,
I can't take credit for this,
'cause this is Dennis Kelly
who wrote this,
who I wrote a sitcom called
"Pulling" with years ago.
So this is his sort of,
you know,
take on the romantic comedy.
But it's set in the lockdown.
-It's a beautiful script.
And he is a playwright, as well.
Is that correct?
-He is, yeah. Yeah.
I mean, it was supposed to be
a play, originally.
But, you know, obviously,
all the theaters
shut down during lockdown.
And then they thought,
"You know, well, we just --
you know, we won't put it on."
But then he just --
I mean, he --
The whole reason why
he wrote the play is,
he was so angry about, you know,
the mishandling of the pandemic,
and he felt
it was really important
that we sort of say
it now, because --
Well, you know,
I mean, everyone seemed to
sort of slightly forget
about how badly handled
it was when
the vaccination came along,
because everyone was like,
"Yay, vaccinations!"
And, so, we decided to film it,
and we filmed it in 10 days.
Stephen Daldry directed it.
And, yeah, we went and filmed it
in one house, one location.
And we filmed it
during lockdown so, you know,
there was all of that
to contend with.
But, yeah, he was just so angry.
He had a lot of anger.
But at the same time,
it is a romantic story.
-It really is.
It's wickedly funny,
it is deeply sad at times,
and it's tremendously romantic.
And when I heard it
was 10 days, I thought,
"That's incredible that they
turned it around in 10 days."
But then there are -- When I
thought about it, I think like
the first 10 minutes
might be a single take.
I mean, that's --
-Yeah, it is.
-Like, that's where it
really feels like --
I mean, it is definitely,
you know, a piece of cinema.
But it really is wonderful
watching the two of you
act in a small space like that.
-I know.
We must have
done that about like --
I think it was
a 20-minute take.
And we had to do it so many
times 'cause we'd, like --
We'd get to the end
and then we'd mess up
just, you know,
before the final hurdle,
and then we'd have to go back to
the start and do it all again.
But we couldn't film it
like regular TV, you know?
So you couldn't do
your sort of --
you know, your close-ups
and your mids and your wides
and all that kind of thing.
You just had to sort of
film it on the move.
-Was it least equitable
who would screw up
a long 20-minute take between
you and James?
-Yeah, it was, actually.
-That's good.
-And thank God,
'cause it just --
It made you feel so awful
when you'd do a good one
and you could really feel it.
No, I think we both screwed up
as often as the other.
Thank God.
-Last we talked,
it was during lockdown.
You have your two daughters,
and they were maybe
giving you a bit of a hard time.
I think one of your daughters
maybe was complaining
that your eyes
were too close together.
We went back and watched.
We don't think that's true.
-Well, I had a little operation.
-Okay.
-I don't know if you can see --
tiny, tiny scar.
-You just took a little bit in?
-Yeah.
I mean, we got through it,
you know?
I mean, unlike "Together,"
I wasn't in a --
you know, in a relationship.
So it was just my two daughters
that I had to contend with.
But I mean, yeah, we're sort of
out the other side.
You know, they're kind of --
I don't know.
Did your kids go back to school?
They did or...
-In the next couple weeks, yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
So it's all sort of
all normal again.
I missed out on
the last term of my --
well, the last two terms of
my youngest daughter,
and then, just as soon as
she goes back to school,
she told me I can't walk her to
the bus stop anymore, so --
And I've already missed, like,
her whole, like,
you know, last year,
and now it's just --
That special time that
we had together,
that sort of
you-and-me special time,
where I'd put my arm around her
and we'd tell each other
secrets -- that's just gone.
That's over.
-I'm very sorry to hear that.
That's deeply unfair.
-Thank you. It is. It is.
-You mentioned
you knew Dennis as a writer,
but I also heard you
had some hesitation of
maybe doing a lockdown film.
How long did that
hesitation last?
-Well, I mean, I --
Yeah, I don't think anyone
who was involved in the film
wanted to do a lockdown film.
Like, Stephen Daldry
didn't want to direct it,
and Dennis
didn't want to write it.
And James and I didn't want
to -- My light just fell off!
[ Laughter ]
-Did it?
We didn't notice or hear it.
-Really? I thought -- Really?
There you go.
Actually, I made some toast
just before we started
and I burned it and I was like,
"The bloody fire curtain is
going to come down,
and the alarm is
going to go off."
But, no, it's just the light.
But, yeah, no,
none of us wanted to do it.
And then I read the script and I
had this mad reaction to it,
because, I mean, you know,
obviously,
it's set in the lockdown,
and, you know, it's about all
the terrible, tragic
things that happened.
But I just found it, like,
really, really romantic.
And I remember
calling Dennis and going,
"This is so beautiful.
I mean, this actually made me
cry, because, you know, I --
You clearly love
your girlfriend very, very much.
And I -- You know, I'm jealous.
I would love to have
a love like that."
But anyone else who
read it was like,
"What are you talking about?
I mean, it's great,
but it's not romantic."
You know, he tells her that
he hates her face,
and she says, you know,
when she thinks about him,
she gets the same feelings
when she thinks about
her dead dad's cancer.
I'm like, "Yeah, but, when he
says, "I probably love you,"
and, you know, when he says
that their love exists
in the place beyond hate,
and they're like,
"But, you know,
he tries to kill her.
She wishes
explosive diarrhea on him."
But -- And there's this --
In the film, like,
not that it's not
a big spoiler or anything,
but -- Well, it is a bit,
but he proposes to her.
And I found out just today that
it was a hidden proposal
from Dennis to his girlfriend,
because he rang me today
and asked me to be his
best person at his wedding.
And I was like, "Yes!
I called it!"
You know, I called it.
I knew it was romantic.
-Well done.
I did not -- Yeah, I was very
surprised to hear that
this work was also
a secret proposal.
That would not have been
my takeaway.
-I know.
It's like the most --
world's most private
sort of Easter egg, I suppose.
-I was also watching it and I
was commenting to someone here.
I was very happy that
James McAvoy,
who's wonderful in it, as well,
he got to be Scottish,
got to use his natural accent.
-He should always be -- Yeah.
-He should always be Scottish.
I agree.
-Yeah.
-Is it true that your kids
give you a hard time
about your lack of
an Irish accent?
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, everyone loves
an Irish accent, right?
And when I take my kids
to Ireland,
they're, you know, charmed by
everyone except me,
except my voice,
because they don't understand --
They just don't
understand my voice,
because, you know, I've lived in
London for 30 years,
and it's all -- You know,
it's a bit of a mishmash.
But I was filming there
in the summer,
and whenever I'm there for any
length of time, it comes back.
Like, I think I sound pretty
goddamn Irish at the moment,
but then they're just like,
"Why are you putting on
that stupid accent?"
You know?
Anything I do, they're just --
-It does seem like
maybe you're in
an impossible situation
with your daughters.
-Yeah, I think
you're probably right.
-Although, you probably have to
bear some responsibility.
I mean, you did --
you did raise them.
-I -- Yeah. I did.
I made them.
-You got to -- There's got to be
very subtle wig work
in this film to show
the passage of time.
Did you enjoy that?
-Well, I enjoyed James'
wig work.
James got to have a man bun,
which is, I mean,
if anyone can pull off a
man bun, it's James McAvoy.
I just got to have really --
Because they wanted to show,
obviously, the passage of time,
because it's over the year
of the lockdown.
And everyone's hair
went nuts, didn't it?
And, you know,
so they gave me extensions.
But, obviously,
to put extensions in,
it sort of just makes your hair
bigger and bigger.
So I looked like
a kind of, like, '80s slut.
And then, you know --
And it feels, like, not right,
but then you take it
out and you really miss it.
It's just gorgeous.
-Well, if we're
talking about '80's sluts,
I would love to show a picture
of my work over the pandemic.
This is not a wig.
This is real hair.
Be honest. What do you think?
-That's -- You -- Yeah.
I mean, it's a little --
You look pervy.
-Uh-huh.
-You look --
-Great.
-Yeah, it's very '80s.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I mean, I don't -- What is that
look that you're working?
-It's Steff -- It's
James Spader's character, Steff,
from "Pretty in Pink."
I don't know if that
made it across the pond.
-Of course it is.
I mean, I genuinely --
I like that --
I mean,
not that particular look,
but I like a sort of
longer-haired look on men.
So I just --
-I don't know if we needed that
qualifier there.
I feel like...
[ Laughter ]
Hey, the movie is
really fantastic.
It is always so good to see you.
Please promise
to come in person next time.
-I will. I'm sorry.
Thanks for -- Because I know
this is a bit ropey, isn't it?
With the old light falling off
and that whole thing.
-No, it's just --
You know, and, you know,
the fact that Sean Penn made
the effort and everything,
it's just --
-I know. I am aware of that.
I deeply apologize.
But I appreciate it.
I am filming in the morning,
at 5:00 a.m., so that's --
-[ Sarcastically ] Oh, my God,
your life is so hard.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks for being here.
It's always so great to see you.
-Thank you.
Nice to see you, too.
-"Together"
is in theaters this Friday,
and "Everybody's Talking About
Jamie" premieres on
Amazon Prime Video
on September 17th.